Hello everyone, it's Tom here with news of a Rest is History special. I am interviewing none other than The Great, the one and only Paul McCartney. He has a new album out, The Boys of Dungeon Lane. Lots of the songs on that album are about his early years growing up in Liverpool. So I'm talking to him about that, about the context, the history that gave rise to the Beatles. And we have a world exclusive here because one of the songs from that album, Salesman Saint, will be featuring in the interview. So incredibly exciting. Enjoy the song. Enjoy the interview. This episode is brought to you by Lloyd's, which has been backing British ambition for over 250 years. Now, when you think about it, every dynasty in history has boiled down to two important elements. Aspiration,
大家好，我是汤姆，为大家带来《Rest is History》特别节目的消息。我采访的不是别人，正是伟大的、独一无二的保罗·麦卡特尼。他发行了一张新专辑《Dungeon Lane的男孩们》。专辑里的许多歌曲都讲述了他早年在利物浦成长的岁月。所以我正与他聊这些，聊聊背景，聊聊孕育了披头士乐队的历史。我们这里有一个全球独家新闻，因为专辑中的一首歌《推销员圣徒》将出现在这次采访中。真是令人兴奋。享受这首歌，享受这次采访。本集由劳埃德银行赞助，该银行已支持英国雄心壮志超过250年。现在，当你思考时，历史上的每一个王朝都归结为两个重要因素：抱负，
and action. And a classic example of this from British history, the rise of the House of Wessex, the family of Alfred the Great and his heirs, who between them established the United Kingdom of England. Yeah, it's a great story, isn't it, Tom? A great lesson in leadership, I think, for anybody. So Alfred and his heirs, they marry idealism and pragmatism. They're brilliant at alliances. They're brilliant at managing power. They're brilliance, of course, at managing their money, which is a key part of political leadership. And of course, we are all reaping the rewards of their wisdom and foresight. When it's time to make your next move, you can bank on Lloyds to be ready when you are. Because from new businesses to new homes and
和行动。英国历史上一个经典的例子就是威塞克斯王朝的崛起，阿尔弗雷德大帝及其继承人的家族，他们共同建立了英格兰联合王国。是的，这是一个伟大的故事，不是吗，汤姆？我认为这对任何人来说都是一个很好的领导力课程。所以阿尔弗雷德和他的继承人，他们将理想主义和实用主义结合在一起。他们擅长结盟，擅长管理权力。当然，他们也擅长管理金钱，这是政治领导力的关键部分。当然，我们都在享受他们智慧和远见的成果。当需要采取下一步行动时，你可以信赖劳埃德银行，随时为你准备。因为从新企业到新家园和
new life chapters, backed by generations of hope and ambition, you can see, Tom, why 14 million people trust Lloyds to help make their dreams a reality. Based on Lloyd's, internal customer data from March 2026. Hello everyone and welcome to The Rest is History and obviously on this show we have talked about all kinds of world historical figures but today is a first because it's the first time on the show that I will actually be talking to a world historical figure and this is a man who is the greatest composer of the 20th century with the Beatles he was a lightning rod for one of the most transformative decades in modern history.
新的人生篇章，在几代人的希望和抱负的支持下，你可以明白，汤姆，为什么1400万人信任劳埃德银行来帮助他们实现梦想。基于劳埃德银行2026年3月的内部客户数据。大家好，欢迎来到《Rest is History》，显然在这个节目中我们谈论过各种世界历史人物，但今天是一个第一次，因为这是我第一次在节目中真正与一位世界历史人物交谈，他是一位20世纪最伟大的作曲家，与披头士乐队一起，他是现代历史上最具变革性的十年之一的避雷针。
And ever since I was about eight, he has been my personal hero. So this is unbelievably exciting for me. And I am talking about, of course, Paul McCartney. Well, that's quite an intro. It's not too much for you, I hope. Not excessive. Hey, come on. Adulation, I don't mind at all.
从我大约八岁起，他就是我的个人英雄。所以这对我来说简直太令人兴奋了。我当然是在说保罗·麦卡特尼。嗯，这真是个不错的开场白。希望这对你来说不会太多。不过分。嘿，来吧。奉承，我一点也不介意。
So we're talking because you've got a new album out. Yes. And this is an album that it's not continuously about it, but a lot of the songs are focused on your childhood, your teenage years growing up in Liverpool. And I was wondering, is this telling us something about what made Paul McCartney who he is? In other words, could Paul McCartney, could the Beatles have emerged from any other city apart from Liverpool, do you think? Was there something distinctive about Liverpool? I think so. Yeah, I was thinking about it recently.
所以我们谈话是因为你有一张新专辑要发行。是的。这张专辑并不是一直都在讲这个，但很多歌曲都集中在你的童年，你在利物浦成长的青少年时期。我在想，这是否告诉了我们一些关于是什么造就了今天的保罗·麦卡特尼的事情？换句话说，你认为保罗·麦卡特尼，披头士乐队，除了利物浦之外，还能从其他任何城市出现吗？利物浦有什么独特之处吗？我想是的。是的，我最近在想这个问题。
I do think the character of Liverpool is a very strong one. I think with the Irish influence and then coming through the war and having to be happy when bombs were falling. So there was a lot of music when I was a kid. My dad played the piano at home. There were a lot of jokes. And so they kept their heads. you know, above water by laughing at the whole thing.
我确实认为利物浦的性格非常鲜明。我认为随着爱尔兰的影响，然后经历战争，在炸弹落下时必须保持快乐。所以当我还是个孩子的时候，有很多音乐。我爸爸在家里弹钢琴。有很多笑话。所以他们保持头脑清醒，你知道，通过嘲笑这一切来维持生计。
And I think that was something that found its way into the Beatles. And I think it gave us a good sense of humor that no matter what we were gonna do, like arrive in America and have the New York press ready to make fun of us, we gave as good as we got. And that was because of our Liverpool upbringing. So you in the new album, you have this song, salesman saint, which is about your parents, your mom and dad.
我认为这是一种进入披头士乐队的东西。我认为它给了我们一种很好的幽默感，无论我们要去做什么，比如到达美国，让纽约媒体准备好嘲笑我们，我们都给予了同样的回应。那是因为我们的利物浦成长经历。所以你在新专辑里有这首歌《推销员圣徒》，是关于你的父母，你的妈妈和爸爸。
And it kind of begins actually in the war, because you were born in 1942, all the Beatles were born in the war. How much of a kind of legacy did the warriors leave in Liverpool and on your kind of personal memories of it? A lot. You were very aware of it. Not the actual bombing. I think all of us were a little too young to experience much of that.
它实际上是在战争中开始的，因为你出生于1942年，所有的披头士成员都出生在战争期间。战争岁月在利物浦以及你对它的个人记忆中留下了什么样的遗产？很多。你非常清楚这一点。不是实际的轰炸。我想我们所有人都太年轻了，没有经历过太多。
Ringo, who's the oldest, he might have some memories, but I don't. But the thing is, you know, the feeling that the grown-ups had, as I say, you know, having to laugh it off, this is a world war. Yeah. But they're just, they've got to carry on, they've got to talk to each other. Because that's one of the lines in the song, isn't it? They had to carry on. Yeah. And they did.
林戈，他是最年长的，他可能有一些记忆，但我没有。但问题是，你知道，大人们的那种感觉，正如我所说，你知道，不得不一笑置之，这是一场世界大战。是的。但他们只是，他们必须继续前进，他们必须互相交谈。因为那是歌词中的一句，不是吗？他们必须继续前进。是的。他们做到了。
That's what I say, you know. And I marvel at that because now, you know, I mean, people can get defeated by the slightest little thing. So compare that to not being defeated by bombs literally raining down on your city. And you've got to find a way around it. And so when I grew up, there was a lot of joy. I think everyone was just so glad to be out of these terrible circumstances. And my uncles were all great joke tell us. And I never heard any of them sort of sitting around.
这就是我所说的，你知道。我对此感到惊叹，因为现在，你知道，我的意思是，人们会被最微小的事情打败。所以把这与没有被字面上落在你城市上的炸弹打败相比较。你必须找到绕过它的方法。所以当我长大时，有很多快乐。我想每个人都因为摆脱了这些可怕的环境而感到高兴。我的叔叔们都是讲笑话的高手。我从来没有听过他们中的任何一个人坐在那里。
Oh, God, life's terrible. You know, there was an honor there. It just, they'd come through it. And so it kind of wasn't allowed. So the bomb damage in Liverpool, it took a long time to repair right. And then you went to Hamburg and Hamburg also was a city that had been wiped out. So when you were kind of making your music, were you aware, were you thinking of, oh, thank God, we're not involved in that? You avoided national service by, I think, by about a year, didn't you, a year or two?
哦，天哪，生活太糟糕了。你知道，那里有一种荣誉。它只是，他们挺过来了。所以它有点不被允许。所以利物浦的炸弹破坏，修复它花了很多时间，对吧。然后你去了汉堡，汉堡也是一个被摧毁的城市。所以当你制作音乐时，你是否意识到，你是否在想，哦，谢天谢地，我们没有参与其中？我想你避开了国民服役，大约一年，不是吗，一两年？
Was the fact that the war had passed and you were kind of in a new age and Liverpool was starting to get back on its feet? Was that something that kind of served as an inspiration? Yeah, I think so. You know, as I say, all of us grew up expecting to go in the Army or National Service. So we were all kind of coasting through our teenage years thinking, oh my God, it's going to happen soon. And then suddenly it was as if God opened the waters and the Israelites could just go through. And that was us We suddenly all of that had gone
战争已经过去，你处于一个新时代，利物浦开始重新站稳脚跟，这一事实是否是一种灵感？是的，我想是的。你知道，正如我所说，我们所有人都成长在期望进入军队或国民服役的环境中。所以我们都在青少年时期随波逐流，心想，哦，天哪，它很快就会发生。然后突然间，就好像上帝打开了水域，以色列人可以直接穿过。那就是我们，我们突然间这一切都消失了
Except for the evidence of it So where we played football Would be on what we called the Bommie Which was the bomb site And we didn't think anything of it was just the Bommi But as later then you go Why did we call it the Bommi Also if there's an un-exploaded bomb
除了它的证据。所以我们踢足球的地方会在我们称之为“Bommie”的地方，也就是炸弹现场。我们没想太多，只是“Bommie”。但后来你再去想，为什么我们叫它“Bommie”？还有如果有未爆炸的炸弹
It could Yeah But you know So that was all around us But we just lived with it and kind of made it part of our lives. And then we were able to, like our parents, able to kind of laugh at everything. And today is, we're recording this on International Midwife Day. Oh, wow. And so that song, Salesman and Saint, your dad was a salesman. Yeah. And your mom was
它可能。是的。但你知道，所以这一切都在我们周围，但我们只是和它一起生活，并把它变成了我们生活的一部分。然后我们能够，像我们的父母一样，能够嘲笑一切。今天是，我们是在国际助产士日录制这个节目的。哦，哇。所以那首歌《推销员和圣徒》，你爸爸是个推销员。是的。你妈妈是
obviously a saint, but she was more specifically a midwife. Yes. That father was a salesman. My mother was a saint. Working every guard give a minute. To make you not to pay the rent. War was nearly over. The peace would soon begin. Living on the edge of the city.
显然是一位圣徒，但她更具体地说是一位助产士。是的。父亲是推销员。母亲是圣徒。每分钟都在工作。为了让你不用付房租。战争快结束了。和平很快就会开始。住在城市边缘。
That was very important, wasn't it, of where you would live because as a midwife she would get kind of houses and you could kind of move around upgrading with each house. That's true, yeah. We moved around quite a lot and didn't realize until we were much older that, ah, that's why we moved. But yeah, she would, and it was often on the edge of the city, you know. But there were nice houses, you know, it was always an upgrade to us.
那非常重要，不是吗，你住在哪里，因为作为一名助产士，她会得到房子，你可以随着每栋房子的升级而搬家。那是真的，是的。我们搬家搬得相当多，直到我们长大很多才意识到，啊，这就是我们搬家的原因。但是的，她会，而且通常是在城市边缘，你知道。但那是很好的房子，你知道，对我们来说总是一种升级。
Because Northland Road had an indoor toilet, didn't it, I think. Wow. The indoor toilet. Yeah, no, it's true. So, you know, we thought we were going somewhere. And my mom was very aspirational, like a lot of good mothers. She just wanted her kids to succeed, do well. I mean, my wife, Nancy, she will say to me, you don't talk Liverpool.
因为诺斯兰路有室内厕所，不是吗，我想。哇。室内厕所。是的，不，这是真的。所以，你知道，我们以为我们要去某个地方。我妈妈非常有抱负，像许多好母亲一样。她只是希望她的孩子成功，做得好。我的意思是，我的妻子南希，她会对我说话，你不说利物浦话。
She said, people love it when you talk Liverpool. I say, yeah, but my mother. My mom tried to get us not to talk Liverpool. She tried to get us to talk posh. She was hoping we'd be doctors or something, you know. But I guess as a midwife, she's a community midwife, right? I mean, she's not working in a hospital. So she has to serve all the community.
她说，人们喜欢你讲利物浦话。我说，是的，但我妈妈。我妈妈试图让我们不要讲利物浦话。她试图让我们讲时髦的话。她希望我们成为医生什么的，你知道。但我猜作为一名助产士，她是社区助产士，对吧？我的意思是，她不在医院工作。所以她必须为整个社区服务。
So there would be, I don't know, people in leafy homes, and then there would be people with very little. And she would have to serve them all, and presumably she would know them all. Yeah, no, it's quite, it's something growing up. Oh, my mom's a midwife, and you don't really think much beyond that. But now you think, wow, you know, just going out and home delivering all these babies and the parents being so in love with you. I mean, they would come around to our house and bringing little gifts, a little statuette or something.
所以会有，我不知道，住在绿树成荫的家里的，然后会有几乎一无所有的人。她必须为他们所有人服务，据推测她会认识他们所有人。是的，不，这很，成长过程中有些事情。哦，我妈妈是助产士，你真的不会想太多。但现在你想，哇，你知道，只是出去为所有这些婴儿进行家庭接生，父母们是如此爱她。我的意思是，他们会来到我们家，带一些小礼物，一个小雕像什么的。
Very cheap stuff. but just to show the gratitude. I have one big memory of her. It was in the winter and it had been a heavy snowfall and she got called up because we had a phone, one phone in the house, and she got called to go to a birth. So she got on her bike,
非常便宜的东西。但只是为了表达感激。我对她有一个很大的记忆。那是在冬天，下了大雪，她被叫走了，因为我们有电话，家里有一部电话，她被叫去接生。所以她骑上自行车，
because they didn't have cars. She got on her bike in this deep snow with her uniform on, with a little suitcase on the back and a little basket on the front. And I have this memory in the streetlights of us cycling out through the snow and thinking, wow, that's pretty brave.
因为他们没有车。她在深雪中骑上自行车，穿着制服，背上带着一个小手提箱，前面带着一个小篮子。我有这个记忆，在路灯下，我们骑车穿过雪地，心想，哇，那真是太勇敢了。
I mean, you know, you just, but you did it. They did it. I was asked to ask you this by my wife, who was a midwife, so she would be delighted by absolutely everything that you've said there. So just sticking with your parents, There's two other things specifically about Liverpool, maybe what makes it distinctive, related to your parents. So both of them kind of came from Ireland, ultimately.
我的意思是，你知道，你只是，但你做到了。他们做到了。我妻子让我问你这个，她是一名助产士，所以她会对你所说的一切感到高兴。所以坚持谈论你的父母，关于利物浦还有两件事，也许是什么让它与众不同，与你的父母有关。所以他们两个最终都来自爱尔兰。
They're kind of lying. I think their origins. Their origins are in Ireland. The family came from Ireland. So that kind of generates a sense in Liverpool that it's not quite part of England, doesn't it? Do you think that was a kind of important part of... I'd never thought of it. You're like that, but you're right, yeah.
他们有点在撒谎。我想他们的起源。他们的起源在爱尔兰。这个家庭来自爱尔兰。所以这在利物浦产生了一种感觉，它不完全是英格兰的一部分，不是吗？你认为那是重要的一部分吗……我从来没想过。你就像那样，但你是对的，是的。
No, we were from Liverpool and, you know, you didn't want to be lumped in with everyone. Yeah. We were like, we thought we were special. And I think at one point it was the second city to London, because it was a big port. Yeah, fabulously rich. Yeah. So, you know, we had a great sense of importance, which waned through the years, you know. But when I was growing up, you definitely thought Liverpool was a very great, grand historic place.
不，我们来自利物浦，你知道，你不想和每个人混为一谈。是的。我们就像，我们以为我们很特别。而且我认为在某个时候它是伦敦之后的第二大城市，因为它是一个大港口。是的，非常富有。是的。所以，你知道，我们有一种伟大的重要感，这些年来逐渐减弱了，你知道。但当我长大时，你绝对认为利物浦是一个非常伟大、宏伟的历史名城。
You used to go down and see all the liners off. Yeah. They all be going off to Canada, you know, places like that. And it was only later that you learn that this was slave trade. Yeah. That there was a lot of that. Only thing we would see would be the local Caribbean people. So we would know people that would be descended.
你过去常去送所有的班轮。是的。它们都会去加拿大，你知道，像那样的地方。直到后来你才知道这是奴隶贸易。是的。有很多那种东西。我们唯一会看到的就是当地的加勒比人。所以我们会认识那些后裔。
We didn't talk about it then. But there was, I guess, a sense of Liverpool as being open to the world. as well as to the rest of England. Yeah. So that what is often said about Liverpool is that it's more open to, say, musical influences, perhaps than other planes. Do you think that was true?
我们当时没谈论它。但我猜，有一种利物浦向世界开放的感觉。以及向英格兰的其他地方。是的。所以关于利物浦经常说的是，它比其他地方更开放，比如音乐影响。你认为那是真的吗？
Because, of course, you know, your love of rock and roll was fundamental to what became the Beatles. Yeah. And, you know, sailors came back from a particularly merchant navy. A lot of them that we would know came back, from America, whether they'd been to like New Orleans or, you know, down south. And they had records that nobody else had. So how would you get hold of them?
因为，当然，你知道，你对摇滚乐的热爱是披头士乐队的基础。是的。而且，你知道，水手们从特别的商船队回来。我们认识的很多人都回来了，从美国，无论他们去过像新奥尔良，还是，你知道，南方。他们有别人没有的唱片。那么你是怎么得到它们的呢？
You'd just, you know, you'd borrow them off somebody. Somebody would know the sailor who had it, and the sailor would let them borrow it. You'd borrow it off them. So it was like a little culture where you'd, the record would go around and we'd all learn it. Because I think for people of subsequent generations, it's hard to get our heads around how difficult it was to access music. You know, we can get it on whatever, just stream it or whatever now. But the idea that it's actually really quite hard to get the physical records or to find the radio stations that it's being played on. So does that make, did that make it, if you were interested in rock and roll or whatever, that you were the, you were kind of a self-selected?
你只是，你知道，你从某人那里借来。有人会认识有它的水手，水手会让他们借。你从他们那里借来。所以这就像一个小文化，唱片会传开，我们都会学习它。因为我认为对于后代的人来说，很难理解获取音乐是多么困难。你知道，我们现在可以在任何地方得到它，只是流媒体什么的。但实际上很难得到实体唱片或找到播放它的广播电台的想法。所以这是否使它，如果你对摇滚乐或什么感兴趣，你就是，你是一种自我选择的？
group of people who would know what you were talking about when you met up and discussed these people. Yeah, that was what it was. You would know certain chords and then someone would know an extra chord. So you would go to his house and learn this extra chord and you build up your knowledge through things like that. None of us ever learned to read or write music, which is kind of an interesting fact. about all the, pretty much all the groups out of the 60s. I remember talking to Jeff Lynn of E.L.O.
当你见面并讨论这些人时，会知道你在说什么的人群。是的，就是那样。你会知道某些和弦，然后有人会知道一个额外的和弦。所以你会去他家学习这个额外的和弦，你通过这样的事情建立你的知识。我们中没有人学会读或写音乐，这是一个有趣的事实。关于所有，几乎所有60年代出来的乐队。我记得和E.L.O的杰夫·林恩谈过。
He says, oh, we just made it up. Yeah. And that's what it was, we made it up. But there's a great strength in me showing you a chord or a riff or something. And it's just going from mind to mind. There's no paper involved. All of what we did, I mean, you know, in this very studio, would be that. It was really immediate transference of ideas and you know I say if you look back on all our histories and our legacy
他说，哦，我们只是编出来的。是的。这就是它，我们编出来的。但我向你展示一个和弦或即兴重复段什么的，有一种巨大的力量。它只是从思想传到思想。没有纸张参与。我们所做的一切，我的意思是，你知道，在这个工作室里，就是那样。这真的是思想的直接转移，你知道，我说如果你回顾我们所有的历史和遗产
it was kind of bardic you know a lot of them didn't write it down you know Irish music was not really I don't think written down it was just played and you learned it and then you played it your way so we had a lot of that And that was really nice for transference of ideas. You would just, should just, we would come in here on a Monday morning, let's say, if we were going to record during the week. And it would mainly in the beginning be John and I. And we would have just written something the week before,
它有点像吟游诗人，你知道，他们中的很多人没有把它写下来，你知道，爱尔兰音乐真的不是，我不认为被写下来，它只是被演奏，你学习它，然后你用你的方式演奏它，所以我们有很多那种东西，这对思想的转移真的很好。你只是，应该只是，我们会在周一早上来到这里，假设我们要在周内录音。而且在开始时主要是约翰和我。我们会在前一周写点东西，
written some songs, and we'd come in and everyone would just gather 10 o'clock, 10.30, 30 in the morning. And George Martin would say, okay, Chad's, what is it? What are you going to do? And we say, oh, well, this one. And we'd play it. Me and John on two acoustics, we'd play it.
写了一些歌，我们会在早上10点、10点半聚在一起。乔治·马丁会说，好了，小伙子们，是什么歌？你们打算怎么做？我们会说，哦，这首。然后我们就演奏它。我和约翰用两把木吉他演奏。
George Harrison would look at it and go, okay. Because immediately he knew what we knew. We'd all learned it all together. Ringo would tap out a rhythm kind of thing, and we trusted him to know what to do. And then 20 minutes later, We were recording that song that no one had ever heard, including the producer. Well, I think, I mean, I think for anyone who's seen the get-back film,
乔治·哈里森看一眼就会说，好的。因为他立刻就懂了我们所懂的。我们都是一起学的。林戈会敲出某种节奏，我们相信他知道该怎么做。20分钟后，我们就录制了那首没人听过的歌，包括制作人在内。嗯，我想，我的意思是，对于看过《回归》纪录片的任何人来说，
watching you come up with get-back, it's been revelatory in those terms. You're kind of, come on, it's get-back. Then you realize, oh, no, he doesn't even know that yet. It's kind of an amazing sequence. Yeah. But presumably that is what, that's what you first bonded with John Lennon over, that you both knew these chords, you knew this music. Yeah.
看着你们创作《Get Back》的过程，在这些方面真是令人大开眼界。你当时想，来吧，就是《Get Back》。然后你意识到，哦，不，他甚至还不知道呢。这真是一个奇妙的过程。是的。但想必这就是你最初与约翰·列侬建立联系的原因，你们都知道这些和弦，你们都懂这些音乐。是的。
And that's what happened when you, well, did you, what was the Walton Fate? Was that the first time you met him? Did you meet him before? First time I met, John, was at the Walton Fate, yeah, through a friend of mine, my best friend at school was called Ivan Vaughn. He was born on the 18th of June, 1942, same day as me in Liverpool. And he knew John, so he introduced me to John. But John pretty much knew what I knew. Actually, in the very beginning, John was playing banjo chords on his guitar because his mom had taught him those chords.
这就是当你，嗯，你是怎么，那个沃尔顿集市是怎么回事？那是你们第一次见面吗？你们之前见过吗？我第一次见约翰是在沃尔顿集市，是的，通过我的一个朋友，我在学校最好的朋友叫伊万·沃恩。他出生于1942年6月18日，和我同一天，在利物浦。他认识约翰，所以他把我介绍给了约翰。但约翰几乎懂我所懂的一切。其实，刚开始的时候，约翰在吉他上弹奏班卓琴的和弦，因为他妈妈教过他那些和弦。
So I would sort of say, well, you know, that could go like this and show him how it was done on the guitar. But it was all very just one-on-one. And did you find that as the quorum formed and then, you know, you became the silver beetles and the Beatles and the Beatles and so on, that as you became better and better and your kind of musically, you became more sophisticated, more knowing, was the kind of infrastructure that enabled you to access music
所以我就会说，嗯，你知道，那可以这样弹，并向他展示在吉他上是怎么做的。但那一切都非常一对一。你是否发现，随着四重奏的形成，然后，你知道，你们变成了银甲壳虫乐队，然后是披头士乐队等等，随着你们变得越来越好，在音乐上变得更加成熟、更加内行，那种让你能够接触到音乐的基础设施，
and also for your music to be promoted, kind of growing up around you? Were there more record shops? Were there, was it easier to get radio stations or whatever? So were you kind of, as the Beatles, moving towards a point where you could have a global market in a way that maybe even Little Richard or maybe even Elvis hadn't,
以及让你们的音乐得到推广的渠道，是否在你们周围成长起来了？是否有更多的唱片店？是否更容易接触到广播电台之类的？所以，作为披头士乐队，你们是否正朝着一个可以拥有全球市场的方向发展，这在某种程度上甚至连小理查德或埃尔维斯都没有做到，
back in kind of 1955 or something. We were hoping for that, you know, that was the idea that was prevalent at the time was that you would do what all these other people had done. Didn't quite know how you were gonna do it, but I think that's half the battle is just having that bold ambition. Yeah.
回到1955年左右。我们当时确实抱有这种希望，你知道，那是当时普遍的想法，你会做所有其他人做过的事情。虽然不太清楚该怎么做，但我认为这就是成功的一半，只要有那种大胆的野心。是的。
So we just assumed we could do it if they've done it. And we'd learned a lot of their tricks. So, and we showed each other how to do it. And then came down to London and there were certain guys down here, mainly guys, that would know the stuff we knew. So I remember the Isley brothers was something that we knew, it was an act we knew because they did twist and shout, which we covered. And then you come down to London and someone say, oh, you know the Isleys? So there was that kind of in-crowd thing, you know. Yeah, it was a lot of fun.
所以我们只是假设，如果他们能做到，我们也一定能做到。我们学到了他们很多技巧。所以，我们互相展示了怎么做。后来到了伦敦，这里有一些人，主要是男的，他们懂我们懂的东西。我记得我们知道艾斯利兄弟，因为他们唱了《Twist and Shout》，我们翻唱过。然后你来到伦敦，有人会说，哦，你认识艾斯利兄弟？所以当时有一种圈内人的感觉，你知道。是的，那真的很有趣。
But kind of so, again, just to reiterate, it's so mad that this music was so kind of exclusive because you had to know if you knew you knew and if you didn't, you didn't. Whereas now you can just kind of absorb it almost like osmosis. No, it's nothing like it is now. You can just hit a button and you can get all the music in the world. Now then it was, I think it made it more special. You know, if somebody had an interesting record, John's stepfather, who was a guy called Dykins, had some cool records. So we'd go round to the house and play the records.
但再次重申，这种音乐如此排他真是太疯狂了，因为你必须得知道，如果你知道你就知道，如果你不知道你就不知道。而现在，你可以几乎像渗透一样吸收它。不，现在完全不一样了。你只需按下一个按钮，就能得到世界上所有的音乐。那时候，我认为这让它变得更特别。你知道，如果有人有一张有趣的唱片，约翰的继父，一个叫戴金斯的人，有一些很酷的唱片。所以我们会去他家听那些唱片。
And there'd be things like Carl Perkins. So we'd, that all got into our act. So we'd learn it, get all the words down. And so that was how you learned. It was just if someone had a record, you played the record and copied all the words out, worked out the chords and the riffs. It was a magic moment. I mean, I learned the riff to That'll Be the Day, Buddy Holly.
会有像卡尔·珀金斯那样的东西。所以我们把这些都放进了我们的表演中。我们会学习它，记下所有的歌词。这就是你学习的方式。如果有人有唱片，你就播放唱片，抄下所有的歌词，研究出和弦和即兴重复段。那是一个神奇的时刻。我的意思是，我学会了巴迪·霍利的《That'll Be the Day》的即兴重复段。
I think Little Richard and Buddy Holly were your great favorites. They were part of them. Buddy Holly was great because he played guitar and he sang and he was out front, which not many of the singers did. Elvis had Scotty Moore who played guitar for him. But Buddy played the lead and did the riffs. So you'd learn off him. And he wore glasses, which I always loved. And he wore glasses, which suddenly made life okay for John.
我想小理查德和巴迪·霍利是你最喜欢的。他们是其中一部分。巴迪·霍利很棒，因为他弹吉他、唱歌，而且站在最前面，这在当时的歌手中并不多见。埃尔维斯有斯科蒂·摩尔为他弹吉他。但巴迪弹主音并演奏即兴重复段。所以你会向他学习。而且他戴眼镜，我一直很喜欢。他戴着眼镜，这让约翰的生活突然变得好过了一些。
John was embarrassed. Anytime he saw girls, he took the glasses off, you know. So you're learning these songs, but then you start to write your own songs. Yeah. And I saw you interviewed on a film that came out recently, I think on the BBC. about your lost bass and you were talking about how when you have a guitar you would kind of take it away and sit in a private room and kind of nurse it almost like going to a psychiatrist and you would talk to the guitar and the car would talk back to you and it would talk to you in the form of a song
约翰很尴尬。每次他看到女孩，他就会摘下眼镜，你知道。所以你在学习这些歌，但后来你开始写自己的歌了。是的。我看到你最近在BBC的一个采访中，谈到了你丢失的贝斯，你说当你有一把吉他时，你会把它带走，坐在一个私人的房间里，几乎像去看心理医生一样呵护它，你会和吉他说话，吉他也会回应你，它以歌曲的形式和你对话。
yeah and I don't think that's what it's like for most people but clearly that's what it's like like for you when did you discover that guitars could speak to you and give you songs must have been amazing to realize it. I mean, I wrote my first song when I was 14, and I suppose that's when I discarded, you know. I remember the things that appealed to me about that song. The song was called I Lost My Little Girl. And someone pointed out to me, my mom had died not too long before that. So probably at the back of my mind, a therapist would probably say, that's what this was
是的，我不认为大多数人是这样的，但显然你就是这样。你是什么时候发现吉他可以和你对话并给你灵感的？意识到这一点一定很神奇。我的意思是，我在14岁时写了第一首歌，我想那就是我开始创作的时候。我记得那首歌吸引我的地方。那首歌叫《I Lost My Little Girl》。有人向我指出，我妈妈在那之前不久去世了。所以可能在我的潜意识里，心理医生可能会说，这就是它的由来。
about. But the guitar was your therapist? And the guitar was the therapist. so, you know, I had a couple of musical ideas. The chords went down, went from G to G7 to C. So there was a bamb, bum, bum, and then my melody went, bam, bum, bum against it. So you had those little tricks that you just learned
关于这一点。但吉他是你的心理医生？吉他就是心理医生。所以，你知道，我有几个音乐灵感。和弦从G到G7再到C。所以有那种砰、砰、砰的声音，然后我的旋律是，砰、砰、砰地与之呼应。所以你掌握了那些你从听音乐中学到的小技巧。
just from listening to music. And yeah, so you put them in and write a song. So once you'd written that first song, it was quite exciting and uplifting. So when did you and John start to realize that actually your songs were really good, that they could measure up to the songs that you'd been kind of learning and absorbing? I think we always thought they were good, because we were cocky little bastards. But as they developed and we started to get a bit more mature in the writing, I think then we started, I remember writing a song, we wrote a song together called From Me to You. And it was pretty straightforward. But in the middle of it, it went to a chord we'd never used before.
只是通过听音乐。是的，所以你把它们放进去，写成一首歌。所以一旦你写了第一首歌，就非常令人兴奋和振奋。那么你和约翰是什么时候开始意识到你们的歌真的很棒，它们可以与你们一直在学习和吸收的歌曲相媲美呢？我想我们一直认为它们很好，因为我们是自负的小混蛋。但随着它们的发展，我们的创作变得更加成熟，我想那时我们开始，我记得写了一首歌，我们一起写了一首叫《From Me to You》的歌。它非常直白。但在中间，它转到了一个我们从未用过的和弦。
And I remember thinking, wow, we're getting sophisticated. We're in C to A minor. Now, suddenly we're doing a G minor. Wow. So around about that period, you know, we started to think pretty good. And then you'd write a song, let's say, like, I mean, what would always happen is one of us would come in with the idea, and then the two of us would finish it up. So something like Norwegian Wood, which was a John idea, and then we sat down and finished it together. I think after that we thought, oh, we're getting somewhere. Well, because that also, I mean, George introduced the sitar. The sitar, yeah. And it was a detail from John, wasn't it? He didn't want to confess that he'd had a fling to Cynthia.
我记得当时想，哇，我们变得复杂了。我们从C转到A小调。现在，突然我们用了一个G小调。哇。所以在那段时间左右，你知道，我们开始觉得相当不错。然后你会写一首歌，比如说，我的意思是，通常发生的情况是，我们中的一个人带着想法进来，然后我们两个人一起完成它。比如《Norwegian Wood》，那是约翰的想法，然后我们坐下来一起完成了它。我想在那之后我们想，哦，我们有所成就了。嗯，因为那也，我的意思是，乔治引入了西塔琴。西塔琴，是的。那是约翰的一个细节，不是吗？他不想向辛西娅承认他有过一段风流韵事。
That's what said. I don't know whether that's true or not. But it's, so around then, the songs are starting to move from, I love you, you love me, she loves you, whatever, to more complicated, more. Almost novelistic stuff. Yeah, and I think that's when we started to think, wow, this is going somewhere, you know. And then you would feel encouraged to write more than just the sort of I Love You songs. I just watched you talking through all the songs in the new album.
那是人们说的。我不知道那是否属实。但，所以在那前后，歌曲开始从“我爱你，你爱我，她爱你”之类的，变得更加复杂，更加。几乎像小说一样。是的，我想那就是我们开始想，哇，这很有前途，你知道。然后你会受到鼓励去写不仅仅是那种“我爱你”的歌。我刚看了你谈论新专辑里所有歌曲的视频。
And you said in that that your song salesman saying to about your parents, that you're kind of inspired by the example of Charles Dickens looking back to his childhood. And the sense I get with you and John as well is actually how kind of how literary you were as well, how informed by reading Lewis Carroll, Dickens or whatever. So was that part of what was starting to feed into the songs around 6965? Yeah, I think that's one of the things that made the Beatles special was that three of us were grammar school boys. So we'd had to learn or be exposed to things like, Lewis Carroll, as you say, Dickens, my case would be like Thomas Hardy and Shakespeare and stuff. So even though we didn't like it at the time, because it was school, it's like, oh, this is boring, you know.
你在里面说你的歌《Salesman Saint》是关于你父母的，你受到查尔斯·狄更斯回顾童年的启发。我和约翰给我的感觉也是，你们实际上是多么有文学素养，多么受刘易斯·卡罗尔、狄更斯等人的影响。那么，这是否是1965年左右开始融入歌曲的一部分？是的，我认为这是让披头士乐队变得特别的原因之一，我们中有三个人是文法学校的学生。所以我们不得不学习或接触像刘易斯·卡罗尔、狄更斯，我个人的话还有托马斯·哈代和莎士比亚之类的东西。所以即使我们当时不喜欢，因为那是学校，觉得这很无聊，你知道。
I think once we started writing, I started to realize, oh, it's fun in its way in here. It's something through. Yeah. It's just, you know, like sponges we'd got it all in our beings. And now we were writing songs. You're starting to realize that like a rhyming couplet, which I would learn about through studying Hamlet from, you know, A-level or whatever. And I always thought that was a cool idea of Shakespeare's.
我想一旦我们开始写作，我开始意识到，哦，它在某种程度上很有趣。它贯穿其中。是的。就像海绵一样，我们把这一切都吸收到我们的生命中。现在我们正在写歌。你开始意识到，像押韵对句，我通过学习《哈姆雷特》学到的，你知道，A-level考试之类的。我一直认为那是莎士比亚的一个很酷的想法。
He just finished up the thing with, you know, I'm going to do it do a bab and a diddla dddddl and going to the bap. Wow. Goodbye. That's the end of that. So I was only years later I realized I'd used that unwittingly in and in the end, the love you take is equal to the love you make. Proceeding that is golden slumbers, which you've kind of, it's literally word for word taken from an anthology of Elizabethan poetry. Yeah. Again, something else that you said about the new album, but I listen to you talking,
他只是用那种方式结束了它，你知道，我要做个砰，再来个滴答滴答，然后进入砰。哇。再见。那就是结局。所以多年后我才意识到，我在《The End》中无意中使用了它，“你付出的爱等于你得到的爱”。在那之前是《Golden Slumbers》，你几乎是逐字逐句地从伊丽莎白时代的诗歌选集中摘录的。是的。又是你在谈论新专辑时说的另一件事，但我听你谈话，
was you've got a song in it about a woman who has married a complicated man, but, you know, she's got the measure of him. And you were talking about how you love to write songs about people, almost like a kind of novelist. Is Eleanor Rigby the first in that kind of sequence? And it goes through Another Day and Jenny Wren. Yeah, probably. No, I like that. I like the filmic thing, you know, I, sometimes I'll write, and I love her, which is, you know, I love so, very straightforward and I think fine for what it is. But then you'll, then I'll start to, you know, because I, you've watched so many films, read so many books, that this character that I'd kind of known women like this, Eleanor Rigby, Lonely old ladies on the housing estate where we lived there were always a couple of old pensioners and I would go around and offer to get their shopping for them or stuff and it was very good because they'd start to tell me
是你里面有一首歌是关于一个嫁给了一个复杂男人的女人，但是，你知道，她看透了他。你谈到你喜欢像小说家一样写关于人的歌。《Eleanor Rigby》是那个系列的第一首吗？然后是《Another Day》和《Jenny Wren》。是的，大概吧。不，我喜欢那种电影感，你知道，我，有时我会写《And I Love Her》，那是，你知道，我爱，非常直白，我认为对于那首歌来说很好。但后来你，然后我会开始，你知道，因为你看了那么多电影，读了那么多书，这个角色，我认识像这样的女人，埃莉诺·里格比，我们住的住宅区里孤独的老太太，总有几个老退休人员，我会过去主动提出帮她们买东西之类的，这非常好，因为她们会开始告诉我
stories of the war or I remember one of the old ladies showing me a crystal radio So it was great. It was very exciting So I liked these ladies So they were always a kind of special character for me. So I kind of wrote Ellen Arrigby from the perspective of one of those ladies. Yeah, because it's an incredible kind of generosity and compassion in everything that you write. And one other song that for me completely exemplified this was a beautiful song. What's it called?
关于战争的故事，或者我记得其中一位老太太给我看了一个矿石收音机。所以这很棒。非常令人兴奋。所以我喜欢这些女士。所以她们对我来说一直是一种特殊的角色。所以我从其中一位女士的角度写了《Eleanor Rigby》。是的，因为你写的一切都有一种令人难以置信的慷慨和同情心。还有另一首歌对我来说完全体现了这一点，是一首美丽的歌。叫什么名字？
Life Can Be Hard. And when I say this song, Life Can Be Hard, you wrote it during COVID. People who haven't heard it may be expecting that it's going to be quite dark and somber. I mean it is so light and joyous and that seemed to me the kind of that is so Paul McCartney that you can get joy out of something as awful as COVID. Yes, well I think you know I think the people who are locked down with their family were forced to be with their family. If you love your family, that could be quite nice. You know, you're suddenly an enforced family time.
《Life Can Be Hard》。当我提到这首歌《Life Can Be Hard》时，你是在新冠疫情期间写的。没听过的人可能以为它会很黑暗和忧郁。我的意思是它非常轻快和欢乐，这在我看来非常保罗·麦卡特尼，你能在像新冠疫情这样糟糕的事情中找到快乐。是的，嗯，我想你知道，我认为那些和家人一起被封锁的人，被迫和家人在一起。如果你爱你的家人，那可能相当不错。你知道，你突然有了一段强制的家庭时光。
and I had the song and minute I heard myself writing life can be hard something told me to just say but then and then that's when we start to get it together again or whatever I didn't want to go down the dark route I wanted to say yeah life can be hard but come on gang we're gonna get this together we're gonna make it happen you know so it's like the salesman saint song you know you know, they had to carry on. I think it's a theme in my stuff, in my writing, that even though stuff is hard, you are going to have to carry on or let it defeat you. And I think that's very much from the wartime years that all of us grew up in.
我有这首歌，当我听到自己写下“生活可能很艰难”时，有什么东西告诉我，只要说“但是”，然后，那就是我们开始重新振作起来的时候，或者其他什么。我不想走黑暗路线，我想说，是的，生活可能很艰难，但来吧，伙计们，我们要一起克服它，我们要让它实现，你知道。所以这就像《Salesman Saint》那首歌，你知道，他们必须继续前进。我认为这是我作品中的一个主题，即使事情很艰难，你也必须继续前进，否则就会被它打败。我认为这很大程度上源于我们所有人成长的战时岁月。
Carry that weight. Yeah. But, you know, as I say, I never heard any of the uncles talk about the war. They would always have a joke, some great joke, that they would tell you. And so you kind of learned that even though that had been a terrible period, and we'd seen the film of Hitler's bombers, sort of clouding the sky, and you'd seen the Belsen pictures of the prisoners coming out
《Carry That Weight》。是的。但是，你知道，正如我所说，我从未听过任何叔叔谈论战争。他们总是会讲个笑话，一些很棒的笑话，他们会告诉你。所以你学会了，即使那是一段可怕的时期，我们看过希特勒轰炸机的电影，遮蔽了天空，你见过贝尔森集中营的照片，囚犯们出来时穿着
striped uniforms, which is why I can never believe people deny the Holocaust. I mean, that is so insane. But, you know, we'd seen all of that, and yet the people we knew, people were living amongst, had gone on and were now so glad to be away from that, that now they were making something of their lives. And I think that's why there was quite a rich period for us, our generation, that we could now, do good stuff and say, hey, it may be bad, but we can work this out. We can work it out.
条纹制服，这就是为什么我永远无法相信有人否认大屠杀。我的意思是，那太疯狂了。但是，你知道，我们见过所有这些，然而我们认识的人，我们生活在其中的人，已经走出来了，现在很高兴能远离那段过去，所以现在他们正在创造自己的生活。我认为这就是为什么对我们这一代人来说，那是一个相当丰富的时期，我们现在可以做好的事情，并说，嘿，情况可能很糟糕，但我们可以解决它。我们可以解决它。
You can work it out. So, I mean, I can understand hearing you say that, why now so many decades on from your earliest years that you might want to go back and look at those early years and see what kind of mirror it holds up to what we're going through now. Can I just end by asking about your memories and the tricks that memory can play? You had a brilliant story about going on a milk flute with George Harrison when you were, I don't know, how, will you 16 or something? Yeah, it would have been. You were hitchhiking, yeah.
你可以解决它。所以，我的意思是，我能理解听到你这么说，为什么在距离你早年生活几十年后的今天，你可能想回去看看那些早年岁月，看看它对我们现在所经历的事情有什么样的映射。我能最后问一下关于你的记忆以及记忆可能玩的把戏吗？你有一个精彩的故事，关于你和乔治·哈里森在，我不知道，你多大，16岁左右的时候，坐送奶车？是的，应该是。你们当时在搭便车，是的。
Yeah, and you've got a great story about a kind of electrical accident that happened to George, but he then, he thought that it happened to you. So can you just tell people what happened there? Yeah, well, we were hitchhiking down. south, which is what one of the songs of the new album is about, and we got a lift from a milk float, which was electric. Those are the only vehicles we knew that were electric, in about four miles an hour, but it was a lift, so we were quite happy. The driver was sitting on the right-hand side, then there was a battery in the middle, and then
是的，你有一个关于乔治发生的一起电气事故的精彩故事，但他后来以为那是发生在你身上。所以你能告诉大家发生了什么吗？是的，好吧，我们当时搭便车去南方，这是新专辑中其中一首歌的主题，我们搭上了一辆送奶车，那是电动的。那是我们当时唯一知道的电动车辆，时速大约四英里，但毕竟搭上了车，所以我们很高兴。司机坐在右边，中间有一个电池，然后
there was the passenger seat in the left-hand side, and George sat on the battery, George Harrison sat on the battery, and... Everything's going fine. We're going along. We're getting our lift. And then suddenly bang! Ah! And he jumps up.
左边是乘客座位，乔治坐在电池上，乔治·哈里森坐在电池上，然后……一切都很顺利。我们正在前进。我们搭上了车。然后突然砰！啊！他跳了起来。
Look, what's that? What's wrong? And he had a pair of jeans with a zip on the pocket. And it had connected with the two points. I was on the crotch. I thought, not on the crotch. No, it wasn't much. No, this is his back pocket.
看，那是什么？怎么了？他穿了一条口袋上有拉链的牛仔裤。它连接了那两个点。我当时在胯部。我想，不是在胯部。不，没什么。不，这是他的后口袋。
So he jumps up and he, oh, bloody. And it had connected up, and the battery had given it. him a bolt and later when we we got to our B&B he showed me yeah he had a great big zip tattooed into his bum but but and the point of what you were saying was so that was always my story and I told it to people then I met Olivia Harrison George's widow quite recently and she was saying oh I love that story of you and George going down to Wales and you sitting on the battery and connecting and you got a scar on your bum.
所以他跳了起来，哦，该死。它连接上了，电池给了他一下电击。后来当我们到达民宿时，他给我看了，是的，他的屁股上有一个巨大的拉链纹身。但是，你刚才说的重点是，那一直是我讲的故事，我当时告诉了别人。后来我最近见到了奥利维亚·哈里森，乔治的遗孀，她说，哦，我喜欢你和乔治去威尔士，你坐在电池上连接起来，然后你屁股上有个伤疤的故事。
I said, it wasn't me. It was George. But I think it's amazing the way memory does that. It can just morph. And it must be even harder for you because you've been so written about. People know things about you that maybe never happened because it's been reproduced in countless That's very true. And that is history. It is. That is, and I now appreciate through all the sort of wrong stories about the Beatles, I realize, you know, that Harold with the arrow in the eye,
我说过，那不是我，是乔治。但我认为记忆的运作方式很神奇，它会发生形变。对你来说一定更难，因为关于你的文章太多了。人们知道一些关于你的事情，可能根本没发生过，因为它们被无数次地转载。这确实是真的。这就是历史。没错。也就是说，通过所有关于披头士乐队的错误故事，我现在意识到，你知道，那个眼睛中箭的哈罗德，
oh, I get it, it was for the tapestry or whatever, you know, all these little things. How can you have accurate history? This is the perfect moat on which you're in. Paul McCartney, thank you so much, and thank you everyone for listening. Thanks. I think of all the things that the rest of history has brought me, the chance to interview Paul McCartney is absolutely up there at the summit. I mean, that's something that I've dreamed of doing since I was about eight. And it was an amazing experience to have him come down the steps from the production booth
哦，我明白了，那是为了挂毯之类的东西，你知道，所有这些小细节。历史怎么可能准确呢？这就是你所处的完美护城河。保罗·麦卡特尼，非常感谢你，也感谢大家的收听。谢谢。我认为在历史带给我的所有事情中，采访保罗·麦卡特尼的机会绝对是巅峰之作。我的意思是，这是我从八岁左右就梦想做的事情。让他从制作室的台阶上走下来，这真是一次奇妙的经历，
in which George Martin had messaged them when they recorded, please, please me. Gentlemen, you've just recorded your first number one. And there was Paul McCartney coming down the steps, having a little chat with him. It was just amazing. When I began the interview, there was a kind of slight tightening of the vocal chords, I think.
乔治·马丁在他们录制《Please Please Me》时曾给他们留言。先生们，你们刚刚录制了你们的第一首冠军单曲。然后保罗·麦卡特尼走下台阶，和他聊了几句。这真是太棒了。当我开始采访时，我想我的声带稍微有点紧绷。
But he was amazingly generous, amazingly personable. I know he's done a million interviews, so he's very skilled at putting interviewers. getting them to kind of feel easy. But it really did feel like a conversation. The only time when it didn't was when Paul started talking about the recording of Norwegian Wood. And I abstracted myself and suddenly looked down and thought, here I am in Happy Road, listening to Paul McCartney talk about how John Lennon wrote Norwegian Wood. And my mind went completely blank at that point and I had this great lurch of panic thinking what on earth am I going to talk to him about now. But actually the
但他非常慷慨，非常平易近人。我知道他做过一百万次采访，所以他非常擅长让采访者感到放松。但这确实感觉像是一次对话。唯一感觉不像的时候是保罗开始谈论《Norwegian Wood》的录制过程。我走神了，突然低头想，我竟然在阿比路，听保罗·麦卡特尼讲述约翰·列侬是如何创作《Norwegian Wood》的。那一刻我的大脑完全一片空白，我感到一阵巨大的恐慌，心想接下来我到底要和他聊什么。但实际上，
the interview flowed in all kinds of ways that I wasn't entirely expecting, which is kind of what made it so fun. And I thought, especially at the end when he started talking about the unknowability of the past and, you know, is the Bay of Tavistry adequate evidence for the Battle of Hastings? And it, I kind of felt then that maybe that was a comparison that he'd never previously drawn in any previous interview. I may be wrong on that, but if so, then I feel very proud. Wonderful, that of all the things that he could have first talked about, his take on the Battle of Hastings, it was, the rest is history. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
采访以各种我完全没预料到的方式进行，这正是它如此有趣的原因。我想，特别是在最后，当他开始谈论过去的不可知性时，你知道，贝叶挂毯是黑斯廷斯战役的充分证据吗？当时我有一种感觉，这可能是一个他以前从未在任何采访中做过的比较。我可能错了，但如果是这样，我会感到非常自豪。太棒了，在他能谈论的所有事情中，他对比黑斯廷斯战役的看法，这就是历史。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。